con 7 años juliana está entre las
ucranianas más jóvenes que apoyan los
esfuerzos de guerra en mi propio aquí
recopilamos las telas para las mechas de
los cócteles mólotov
un poco más lejos se recupera el
poliestireno utilizado para las mezclas
químicas de las bombas incendiarias
es aquí donde son fabricados por estas
mujeres que trabajan sin descanso
esta de aquí piensa especialmente en su
esposo
estando aquí ayuda a mi marido aunque
preferiría estar con él en el frente
para sacar al enemigo de nuestro país
es así como los civiles ucranianos
arrojan estas bombas caseras a los
tanques curiosos
[Música]
dentro de este taller de costura las
estilistas ya no fabrican trajes o
accesorios de moda sino uniformes y
chalecos antibalas
la placa de metal la envía a otro grupo
de la resistencia y luego es probado con
munición real por un tercer grupo
chalecos aún más importantes a medida
que se levantan las barricadas en ny pro
hay mujeres entre los obreros pero
también se incluyen soldados como anna
doctora y voluntaria
no tengo miedo y mi hijo de 21 años
también se enlistó estoy soy vocal no
decir que you tomó después de 2018 las
mujeres son consideradas iguales a los
hombres dentro del ejército ucraniano
ellas representan hoy el 15% de la
fuerza